all righty then
let's watch from how it should have
ended how Sonic the Hedgehog should have
ended why talk anymore
subscribe to his e if you haven't done
so already they don't need our promotion
this episode is sponsored by honey free
online shopping tool that helps you save
money just go to join honey calm /h is a
chi to download for free to the
description very sweet
[Music]
who are you you don't know it yet but
we're your friends do oh really oh no
you are not doing it if you're going to
have an Avengers portal scene uh cough
then I'm going to have one too
that's a great Jim Carrey the Great
Depression Oh
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they're really know they're Sonic
characters
no exam the world
[Music]
give me a kid I'm gonna execute a blood
cake batter super slow-mo
[Music]
horse neighs I've only got one question
for you do my food now
you're storing all the Jim Carrey's
filmography seem to be in charge hear me
doctor that's doctor sorry he was just
blowing up the town so I just thought
I'm a cop and I have a gun poor guy
trying to shoot me with a dart if I
wasn't super fast and fully capable of
gods and speeding objects I would think
this could be the beginning of a
beautiful friendship together that does
sound pretty cool maybe I should let her
hit me
yeah I should remember what that random
lady taught me always you imagine that
would have been cool that would be
almost as cool as DC and marvel crossing
that would be a guy surprise John Bailey
I was wondering if he was a Jim Carrey
yeah
how much longer breathing here do you
have your child in that bag no I mean
yes it's a child but it's not mine it's
not your child no no yeah this is very
strange behavior I would just hate
myself if I didn't call the honey is
good honey is a free online shopping
tool that automatically searches the
internet for the best promo code we have
not we are - honey is perfectly
authentic boy honey free and it only
takes two clicks to install just go to
join honey calm /h is a team I support
this is my support of this sponsorship
money supports over 30,000 stores online
and it's founded 17 million members over
two billion dollars in savings
so click the link below and add honey to
your browser today or go to join honey
calm /h is 18 okay that's all for now
thank you so much again for watching we
hope you're doing well be sure to LIKE
and subscribe if you haven't you know
Thank You se for still working your
asses off during this time thank you
yeah bringing us the entertainment other
this was a really inventive one I
actually preferred it in a lot of ways
over the actual one yeah this is like
too long sketches almost this feels a
little bit more akin to how it should
have ended has done it in the beginning
you kind of just had a couple of bits
were now what they usually do is like a
whole bunch of random like a medley of a
whole bunch of bunch of alternate jokes
hey yeah yeah exactly this one was just
to primarily it's like I had the Stinger
at the end with the elevator moment
which is a genuinely funny moment in the
film they just focus on making two
scenes which I thought was different and
to that extent at that point I kind of
felt like they were coming from a rather
genuine place with this one yeah as
opposed to just making fun of it and
just making jokes like you had you're
equipping lives all the Jim Carrey's and
all the Sonic the Hedgehog characters
but this seems like a coming from a
place of a real genuine fanfiction side
here's what they would have liked to
have seen done because awesome well the
sonic character show up like yeah the
Jim Carrey's would have been ridiculous
and like come on what the hell's going
on and like that's for the hizzy comedic
purposes however the ones with the ring
and all the Sonic and honestly even
showing up any any encounters Mario that
probably would have been a really cool
ending like that seems like the hizzy
fans were evil who delve into animation
probably really know their Sonic and
their Nintendo world very well and its
showcases here so it was interesting to
get a variation of car kane' back to the
old days of how it should have ended by
keeping it more simplified in just a
couple of scenes and also seeming like
they probably would have actually
genuinely preferred at least half of
this really occur in the film well it
also just goes to highlight I never
thought about that during the scene
where ours didn't caps him with the
tranquilizer for the first time I was
like oh yeah this would probably be a
very avoidable situation for Sonic
wouldn't it
because so many of those Quicksilver
type moments play out where he's
obviously having fun with the slow-mo
well I think in the scene though in the
movie he had been always stalking James
Marcin and that was the first time he'd
come face to face so he was emotionally
he's thrown off by it he was yeah he was
coming to him in a moment of desperation
he was off guard so you know I will
defend Sonic the Hedgehog he's logical
so he says no but Jim Carrey impression
was really good that John Bailey I
thought makes great yeah it sounded like
that was a really good Jim Carrey
impression yeah Alan just to get the
robo versions of all the different
characters and all the puns and
one-liners that come out of that and and
yeah it is the perfect level or like you
said if that had to happen in the movie
you would be like huh here it was the
perfect yeah a little fanfiction it just
yeah I felt like they didn't even need
to go base this super heavily off the
movie he didn't know they did it in a
weird way the fact that Jim Carrey
shipped dr. Robotnik's ship his face was
exposed the glass was not concealing him
so someone could have shot him one cop
who spends the entire film being
completely incompetent could've had the
help and I loved how they played him to
just come out like this seemed like
somebody had to do something it is
really on the market yeah it was nice to
go back to the old school vibe a little
bit it's different than what I expected
all right guys well subscribe to his
events already subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bill
last but not least Chris swam off and
Daniel Galica chrislam off our great
friend from Michigan Dan Gallagher are
awesome pharmacists from Scotland
thought it'd be fun for them this month
we do some patreon fanfiction of what if
our patrons met I haven't read it John
wrote this one so strap in take it away
John interior local Scottish pharmacy
day enter Chris wham off looking like he
just rolled out of the goddamn Robocop
apocalypse ducks under one arm and a
fistful of Hope under the other across
the counter Daniel Gallacher sexy young
Scotsman approaches ready to serve up
some piping hot absolutely legal drugs
welcome to the official pharmacy of
Scotland can I help ya and he ducks lots
of ducks
those Ducks are for medical use only do
you have a prescription what's your name
kid
Daniel gala Connor from Scotland well
Daniel Gallagher from Scotland tell me
this is always what you wanted to do
because I'm down to my last two ducks
and I've got some kids to bring joy to
it's a matter of fact Chris one more
Oh my name what did you say that name
because I know yeah Chris impossible
what'd I do you're an inspiration but of
course you did you're a work and mental
health is what inspired me if our mercy
tickles that isn't quite how old are you
now don't be modest you don't look a day
over 21 that's not what I well come on I
don't know what you brought all the way
out here the Glasgow Scotland from
Kalamazoo Michigan the United States of
America northwest hemisphere planet
Earth but it truly is an owner well
thanks man but that's kind of you now
about those ducks oh yeah you said you
had some kids to bring joy to you no I
was going to bring them to Greg and John
over at the real rejects there's a major
therapy duck shortage out in Los Angeles
but you've touched me today oh no I
swear it's against company policy no
you've touched my heart
here take these dogs the music swells is
Daniel and Krista tearfully from the
Ducks to each other then to the Ducks
again I'll buy that for a dollar me too
and that's the story of how Chris and
Daniel met I have no idea what I just
read I know I know I was going back
through some old messages just
reminiscing about old times and you know
Chris obviously does a lot of mental
health work Daniel obviously does a lot
of valuable work in the pharmaceutical
so I thought maybe these guys could have
a Venn diagram of interests but then I
got absurd in the process Chris is a
creative guy and he does a lot to help a
lot of people with both their physical
and mental recovery from a lot of dark
situations and I was like that seems
like something so nice
so yeah I don't know why that weird
detail became the crux in the sketch but
we love you both and thanks so much for
being here and for being you stay safe
out there especially you Chris Scottish
seems a little safer than give me more
to edit thanks John